dude if the dog cocked it and
yeah that's true right
sites and everything
[Music]
a 32 year old man in Turkey was
reportedly shot and killed by his own
dog after the canine stepped on the
trigger of a shotgun
how what the [__] [__]
Dude That's like [__] you turning on
the gas at home with the [__] dog
imaginary dog pounding back another
fanny pack you equate that to Nick
that's something that happened to Nick
hey man a [__] your dog [__] blew
your brains out with the shotgun so you
think if I die I'm gonna die like that
yeah why was there a loaded shotgun on
the ground well so he was actually even
on there he was out hunting with his
friend okay
um in a place called The Kills in
Plateau okay in Turkey nice name he's
putting his dog into his car the
animal's paw touched the gun which was
in the car and then the rifle fired him
is the [__] trigger in the shape of a
bone
maybe it's a big meaty dog oh was his
friend the only one there yeah I think
so yeah it was just him and his friends
but his friends shot him and blamed it
on the dog oh [__] that's that's
interesting after the dog shot him the
fingerprint was his friend's fingerprint
it's like a Dick Cheney thing in it yeah
oh when he was hunting yeah I know that
hunting accident classic hunting
accident just like the stove turning on
by itself yeah kitchen accident hey dude
Remember The Walking Dead yep it's like
hey let's go uh hunting real quick and
[__] yeah it was Shane versus that
versus Rick Grimes and [__] come on nah
or like Lenny and [__] uh Gary Sinise
in the movie oh Mice and Men oh yeah
think about that think about the wagon
remember Garrison's man yeah yeah I
forgot is that a book like can you just
because he was in CSI New York okay he's
starting to see us at New York that was
my favorite show as a kid
the character by John Steinbeck
what was his name I don't remember but I
just want to make the George George
no I like Garrison he's better dude he
was the captain in uh Forrest Gump yeah
he was oh yeah
there's [__] hated Lieutenant Dan man
why are you [__] with my boy he was a
dick
he was just a broken man yeah he was
[__] up he got problems oh wait no
nothing about another movie I'm thinking
about uh a few A Few Good Men is that
Cuba Gooding Jr what movie have you
watched part is that is that is that can
we go to Junior's not in the future
wait that guy's not even in that movie
dude you didn't name anyone I mixed up
all these millions you can't talk about
movies no more of it no I mixed them all
up
Black Hawk Down
they're all mixed up she's in uh tell me
all these Naval movies saw the Power
Rangers movies this year he's like it's
pretty good I hate Cuba Gooding and
Glenn Gary Glen Ross
um so they took his body to the morgue
and then there's an investigation
underway to actually determine the
details they put the dog on the stand
damn yeah what happens then if your dog
if it was a true accident
do you does the dog get put down that's
a really good for involuntary
manslaughter yeah I think it just goes
on neglect does it go to the pound
dollar yeah because if the dog bit him
the dog yeah the dog gets put down but
if it's a [__] what if it's a human
Contraption but what happens if like now
that that dog doesn't have an owner gets
the dog gets like a new owner and then
for whatever random reason the dog
shoots their second owner they probably
put that dog down okay because this is
two chances this would be the same thing
like let's say you had a dog
in riding shotgun and you're like oh
what's that my car's not working so you
go to the front of the car and the dog
jumps on the driver's side and steps and
runs your ass over it's kind of like
it's kind of cute it's kind of tough but
it's kind of your fault yeah you know
they train these three dogs how to drive
it's pretty funny do you see that you
know they are they have Mini Coopers and
these three [__] dogs are just
driving now I'm in I don't know how to
[__] switch gears it's crazy I've
seen the dog on the [__] the the
scooter oh yeah or a skateboard well
they put it in a drive you could call me
at any hour of the night and send that
to me all right yeah for sure so yeah
send more dog videos kind of [__] I want
to see I've seen dogs using toilets I've
seen that JP and poo in there and they
know how to flush it after that is crazy
so this man had become a father 10 days
prior to this
Australian shepherds are so cute and
after and after the shot was fired the
dog reportedly put it to fall like this
one
like gifts
it covered everything yeah how did the
article write that part like what was
the uh word for word it's like yeah word
for Words
there's a diagram sure dotted line a
wistful sound the dog was sad it was
yeah it was sad damn
that's [__] up dude yeah but uh I
pictured a more of a golden retriever
but oh yeah I pictured a pie I don't
know what kind of dog is I just made it
a pug it doesn't say a hunting plug yeah
and it actually has a stock image of
just some dog yeah that's the best part
about this it's like it's like a
pedigree [__] ass and look look what
it says right here I was the old guy
this stock even shows a dog sitting
outside okay thanks turkey thanks guys
this is not you don't it's not coverage
people wonder why I make up details
because there's no details when you die
they say your your life flashes before
your eyes yeah so if it flashes and then
it goes to the part where you see your
dog stepping on the trigger you'd be
like man I'm a [__] [__] dude when
you look when you look up and this dog's
like wagging
yeah buddy you're like what are you
serious that's how I went out it was you
you son of a [__] I remember this it
was used that's for not giving me treats
does he point
so that his resting place is pointing at
the dog
and the dog's like
so that's just that's just not leaving
the safety on huh and it's loaded some
guns don't have a safe don't load it
okay should you is that bad gun
etiquette to put your load of gun on the
floor
no not technically not
it's technically not so it's the dog's
fault then I mean if you're hunting and
you're out in the woods but let's be
real Bart if this was like on Twitter
and the gun Community scholarship
I mean it could be because those guys
don't even [__] do anything for reals
that's crazy odds that you left the gun
in a way that was pointed at a vital
organ yeah and accessible by pause yeah
yeah it's kind of uh one in a million in
it because I'm sure like
well for shotguns right is the trigger
pretty like hard to pull it all depends
on the gun dude if the dog cocked it and
yeah that's true right
s and everything loading the shelves
themselves with [__] no opposable
thumbs he has it in his mouth
thank you
that's right dude
and the whole time the owner's like no
stop don't don't [__] the gun don't you
load it don't load it don't take the
bikes out don't pop it before the front
it bends forward yeah
[Laughter]
front end of this shotgun off
he bites everything damn I wish he
didn't have a kid it's like a less fun
oh no yeah
take the kid part out of the artist yeah
can we forget about that can we just say
that that didn't happen let's go back to
the part where the dog is sawing the
shotgun and has goggles on at least it's
a shotgun it could have been like a
machine gun and it would have been oh my
God
it's a musket in the Fool's [__]
putting gun powder in or it could have
been a full a full auto Sig Sauer yeah
it's going crazy that we're like how
does that exist
those are funny images I have in my head
now like dogs on like 50 cows dogs with
guns anything at the perform sizing
animals I'm in yeah dude you put an
animal in a parachute you put an animal
in a tank you put an animal in a plane
I'm in yeah every time do you like those
Navy SEAL dogs they like they jump out
of the planes with them and then they
have [__] goggles on too so really so
[__] cool I love when they give a dog
like a [__] medal but they don't know
what the [__] is happening yeah it's
just a dog's nose like they get a key to
the city yeah but the dogs are sitting
there and then they give them a [__]
medal and then the dogs
[__] makes me [__] die you know what
I saw I saw on a Veterans Day there's
this dog so he had like four deployments
to Afghanistan and if there's this one
restaurant that honors like all vets so
the dog is sitting at the booth like
this and then the owner is like cutting
and giving them French toast no really
he's a vet technically and so he was
like giving them [__] French toast
veterinarian bacon that's no idea what's
going on yeah he has no clue yeah he's
just like thank you for four tours this
one's for Libya this one's for
Afghanistan do you think there's do you
think there's dogs out there that are
doing Stolen Valor
poor Taurus hey Dalmatians didn't serve
y'all were working at home in the
firehouses
[Music]